Christian veil have started dozens of
box-office hits they include of course
the Dark Knight trilogy where he played
Bruce Wayne and Batman Bale won an Oscar
in 2010 for his performance as Dickie
Eklund in the fighter he also earned
applause from critics for films like
American hustle and the big short his
new movie hostiles is a Western drama
set in 1892 it follows army captain
Joseph blocker on a journey to escort a
dying Cheyenne war chief and his family
back to their native land
so bale plays the captain in this clip
he expressed his reluctance about being
ordered and ordered is a word to help
his rival I saw what happened to the
fourth when yellow hawk and his dog
soldiers got done with him and there was
enough don't you dare laugh it wasn't
enough left of those poor men
if it was slop they'll understand when
we lay our heads down out here we're all
prisoners I hate him
I've got a war bag of reasons to hate on
Christian Bale good morning and well I'm
embarrassed I walked in the green room
and ran right past you and that's it
where is Christian Bale is there in the
black-and-white check shirt had to go
back oh hi Christian Bale so we'll talk
about your new look in just a second but
first let's talk about hostiles right
because Scott Cooper said that he wrote
this part for you yes so number one I
think that's a great feeling but that
doesn't mean you take the part so you
read it and you thought what because
there's intense it's very it's very it
tells the story of America in many ways
it's it's raw is visceral but that is
American history it's violent the last
American history as well it's gripping
beyond belief it's it's all about
overcoming hatred and bigotry as you see
there you know he's a bigoted and
hate-filled man well there's the big
difference in that blocker the character
that you see there would wonderful actor
book camp his job is is to well it's
genocide his job is genocide and he
knows that he's an intelligent man this
isn't your mom and pops a cowboy Western
with black hat and white hat you know
good cowboy bad Indian it's not that at
all it's a whole different era it's
recognizing the genocide the great pain
upon the part of Blocher he's seen his
friends killed by a yellow hawk played
by Wes Studi so the hatred is real and
it's then and then he's threatened with
court-martial he has to transport yellow
Hawk to a sacred burial ground yeah and
it's about how do you overcome hatred
how do you overcome fighting without
rendering the deaths of your friends and
brothers in arms meaningless so it's a
physical journey it's also an emotional
journey absolutely yeah yeah and and
it's one that's become
surprisingly sadly relevant more so
since since we stopped filming you know
in terms of America's some Americans
ease and comfort now and expressing
hatred towards those different from them
you see that this movie is relevant to
this absolutely so absolutely
well in terms of in terms of that in
terms of in every way not respecting the
other not respecting people who are
different from yourself and and in terms
of you know it's well past time that in
politics and in Hollywood the white men
ran run everything you know we need so
much more diversity we're going to get
so much River richer culture because of
it we didn't intend that when we were
making the film but we've seen these
changes these shifts in America since
since we shot it and so it's become more
and more relevant you actually learned
at least some of a Native American
language language oh man so poetic and
we well had this wonderful advisor chief
Philip who's a chief for the Northern
Cheyenne and he would do a blessing
every single morning for the whole crew
which the producers and the ADEs would
be really nervous about because it's
always about panic about time time time
on film and that would take some time
but it enhanced everything so much you
would have these grizzled horse
Wranglers and stunt men just bawling
their eyes out and it's a very raw piece
so it helped us with that and I think
helped enhance the film incredibly
helped me so much with my performance
I'm very indebted to it you feel it for
that can I ask you Gail did mention that
you do look a little bit different than
last time do look a little bit different
she walk straight past me you put on
some weight but for a role quite a long
wait yes did you put on I thought it
wasn't just for fun that I decided to
shave my head bleach my eyebrows 40
pounds I was playing there already Pat
I missed a Dick Cheney in a film which
we were wrapped last week this is a
canvas by which these superb makeup
artists create Cheney
forty pounds just eat anything I did
that when I was pregnant did you just
eat whatever you wanted when you wanted
it was the first time in my life that I
realized that I had to do this in a
smart way I've lost weight I've gained
weight I never went to a nutritionist in
my life it was the first time that I
said you know what I really do this the
right way and why don't you think like
that now well because in the past like
for losing weight I went out just smoke
and drink whiskey and then and it works
mid-forties now doesn't work so well now
I just thought you know probably just
eating cream puffs non-stop it's not
gonna be my ticket there's a great
program called Weight Watchers highly
recommend it for you now I guess not now
after Christmas after Christmas after
Christmas it's so good to see you good
to see it's a lovely film really very
good I can't wait to see who's Dick
Cheney I wouldn't have put the two of it
you together next year it's called
acting thank you Christian Bale hostiles
opens in theaters on Friday it's good go
prepared